Bertram usually traditionally gets made
the night before and left in the fridge
I find that a little bit too heavy and
slightly stodgy so it's the same
principles but a lot lighter first in
the yogurt I think live and raw milk
yogurt are best they're packed with
calcium enzymes and probiotics which
help your body absorb nutrients
it's interesting
because the kids especially would prefer
their muesli with milk but the yogurt
it's so much better for them I like
making it literally 10 minutes before I
want to serve it because it doesn't
become stodgy yogurt in apple juice has
a great way of sweetening the music a
couple tablespoons in
give that a little mix
now
sprinkle in the oats
I like putting two thirds in now to
absorb an almost double in size and the
last third of oats in at the end oats
are low on the glycemic index which
means they slowly release energy to keep
you going right through to lunch I quite
like it when it just falls off the spoon
you can see literally in seconds it's
got thicker
the rest of the oats in
so I've got different textures now mix
that up nicely
and it literally takes three or four
minutes to put together
it's gonna get a dry pan on
almonds incredibly healthy toasting them
even better flavor
flake them into the pan lightly toast
them that gives a really nice sort of
crunch to the top of the music
[Music]
roll them around the pan so they're
evenly toasted
out into a bowl
the exciting thing about putting your
own music together is that you're in
control blackberries summer raspberries
strawberries and so it changes berries
don't just taste great they're packed
with antioxidants and vitamin C and K so
just dot the top of your muesli with
your blackberries generous on the
blackberries
sweetness tartness
acidic
and then just sprinkle over
feel nice
I quite like a lot of crunch on top
so be generous
that looks fantastic
perfect way
to start the day
my quick Burcham usually doesn't just
taste incredible it makes you feel
fantastic it's my ultimate healthy
breakfast there really is no better way
to start the day
[Music]
big and bold when I was living in France
I stayed there for three years once
twice a week I treated myself to the
most amazing
bold breakfast and they started off with
these Beauties here mergys cheap but
incredibly tasty
start off with a nice hot pan my gaze in
it's a very spicy sausage doesn't need
any help doesn't need any chili just a
touch of salt and pepper
you can smell the spice let's start to
release all that wonderful oil that
flavor in there
add a couple of cloves I'll finely
sliced garlic
spread the garlic across the pan it
instantly changes color takes on this
nice dark Rich golden color
now take a look with the heat out for
the parsley
the stalks of soft herbs like parsley
and coriander can be used to impart
flavor during cooking but the leaves
should always be added just before
serving to give maximum color and
fragrance
[Music]
and then finish that off with my capers
amazing
now take your quest on
they're literally 24 hours old so
they're crispy on the outside and just
slice off
the lid
this recipe is a great way to use up any
leftover croissants from the day before
I used to cringe when I saw the French
Cooks throw away croissants I used to
cry thinking oh my God
you any idea what you're throwing away
in terms of flavor whatever you do do
not wipe out that pan dunk your
croissants mopping up all that amazing
flavor and caramelizing the inside
for that beautiful don't forget the lids
and then get your thumbs and go inside
the croissant
all I want to do now is create a little
pocket
and just manipulate the question now
this is where it gets exciting
mix up the Capers the garlic the
sausages look at the color all that
wonderful delicious flavored oil now
some cheese but not just any cheese
Fontina cheese is like the number one
cheese for grilling and because it's a
very rich cheese you shave it thinner
than you would a white truffle but it
gives a really nice saltiness and a
light Smoky flavor
place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds on the grill
here we go
crisp
packed full of Flavor now top them
and that for me
it's almost like being back in Paris
except this time
I don't have to share them with the
French
My ultimate big and bold breakfast
mergers and Fontina stuff croissants a
great way to start the day I've never
forgotten I think I was about six years
of age where Mum brought this huge tray
of eggy bread to the table and it was
like wow man we've died and gone to
heaven start off with a slightly stale
bread
before five day old loaf left over if
it's a fresh bread then it absorbs too
much of the egg so therefore it gets
soggy you never get it fried and Crisp
And if you're not going to use the
breadcrumbs eggy bread is a must
in France they call it pan Perdue the
Lost loaf
now eggy bread is great on its own but
serving it with stewed apples is
delicious so the secret here
keep the skins on a lot of flavor in the
skin and also it stops the Apple from
breaking down too quickly
they have these nice chunks as opposed
to sort of Apple puree
[Music]
now get your pan nice and hot then
sprinkle a couple of tablespoons of
sugar
take the sugar down to a light caramel
it's quite incredible how cheap it is to
make this and yet it was so filling
if you haven't got apples this recipe
will work pretty much with any fruit
you've got in
get a mix a pear and an apple a banana
and a pineapple just chew it lightly
tossing the caramel get a little knob of
butter
that makes a nice toffee Apple flavor
really simple
now
you can see what's happening the apples
are caramelizing but they're staying
intact because the skins on the apple
and the caramel is turned into this nice
rich butterscotch sauce
once you've glazed all the apples a
couple of tablespoons of water in there
bring that to the ball and let that cook
out now the eggs
three whole eggs
whisk up the eggs
add about four tablespoons of milk you
want the egg thick and Rich and then
lightly sprinkle in a couple tablespoons
of sugar
that sweetens up the mixture and when
you start frying the bread
it caramelizes it usually a teaspoon of
powdered cinnamon that gives the bread
that really nice spicy deliciousness
apples are glazing Goose Fleet
and put them on a low heat and get a pan
on now for the bread
teaspoon of oil that stops the butter
from burning butter in
so that starts frothing get your bread
in it's gonna be pretty quick now now
you don't leave the bread soaking
train
and in the pan
once your egg bread has browned flip it
over
90 seconds each side that butter gives
that nice golden brown color of the egg
[Music]
absolutely beautiful
it's quite remarkable isn't it a couple
of eggs splash of milk leftover apples
and all of a sudden you've got this
stunning breakfast
[Music]
now my apples they've all glazed
beautifully
get a nice spoon of that amazing juice
and drizzle that over
if my mum saw me doing this it should
kill me you're getting all Posh again
none of them I'm using a touch of ice
sugar to make it look stunning
and that for me takes me back to when I
was six years of age
and I thought
I just won the lottery that is
incredible
eggy bread
[Music]
you won't get more breakfast for your
buck my mum's incredibly delicious
cinnamon eggy bread with quick stewed
apples
[Music]
foreign